vous devez boire là vous devez bord
vraiment où le ratio n'est jamais de la
vie
mais cela met en garde chez toi
[Applaudissements]
oh
et c'est pas possible ça pas de vous
[Applaudissements]
accueillir maintenant ah ouais je sais
qu' on a alors ouais ouais c'est pokémon
[Applaudissements]
seri jean luc joly qui s'est passé
quelque chose et un instant il n'y a pas
la plus jeune avait beau ici on va pas
vous montrer les images qu'on va à
l'elysée pour aujourd'hui à l'échelle de
la vallée ses collègues là je sens que
tout le monde adore voir je vais
expliquer je vais expliquer le contexte
mais jean-luc parce que expliquera mieux
le contexte l'absolu rochette dans les
quartiers en fait preuve en est ce qu'en
fait je vous êtes en train de danser au
moment j'ai dit à mathieu delormeau
viens danser aussi hélas est-ce qu'on va
les images où il fait le beau tout ça et
après la le le délire on l'a ou pas avec
le son est tout aussi vous plaindre j
pour d'autres téléspectateurs en or est
imminent
oui on en a mais remercie
[Applaudissements]
je
méchant
c'est pas con qu il a doublé de volume
qu'est-ce qu'il a une fois qu'à une
chose qui double de volume chez vous
[Applaudissements]
allez
pourquoi
à
[Applaudissements]
abidi qui tient pas redoublés gicla
lamensch sfm à lui on s'en fout mais
[Rires]
attends attends mais vas-y
[Applaudissements]
cailleux
batterie
non
alors valérie vous la ramenez chez elle
vous êtes en bas de chez elle
d'accord alors que tu lui dis bon ba al
islah écoute j'ai passé une très bonne
soirée j'aimerais bien te revoir demain
et puis est ce que je t'ai dit
[Applaudissements]
et